président deuxème invité politique à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier monsieur
roberu monsieur bonsoir B bien alors je
suppose que vous ne pensez pas comme
Monsieur Giscard desestin est-ce que
vous pensez vous de votre côté qu'on est
vraiment passé là aujourd'hui peut-être
d'une crise sociale à une véritable
crise politique vous savez ce que des
millions et millions de Français disent
actuellement expriment actuellement ils
disent une chose simple ils disent il
faut retirer le plan Jupé et il faut
négocier c'est très simple il y a une
grande question sociale qui est posée
les Français volulent la négociation il
faut bien reconnaître qu'actuellement
monsieur Jupé s'obstine à être sourd et
je voudrais dire que évidemment il y a
des problèmes de société qui sont posés
vous savez dans ce mouvement les gens se
parlent ils parlent de l'avenir de leurs
enfants ils parlent de l'avenir du pays
sur toutes ces questions évidemment il y
a des réflexions qui sont portées mais
je répète il faut absolument que
Monsieur Jupé entende ce qui se passe
actuellement vous dites il faut retirer
le plan Jup mais vous n'êtes pas contre
toute réforme de la Sécurité sociale
mais certainement pas il faut absolument
réformer la sécurité sociale d'ailleurs
nous avons des propositions concrètes
pour réformer la la la sécurité sociale
nous disons que je je vais les résumer
un nous pensons qu' il faut taxer les
revenus financiers au niveau
actuellement des de la taxation des des
cotisations des salaire ça rapporterait
actuellement 167 milliards c'est la
première mesure la deuxième mesure c'est
que nous nous pensons qu'il faut
voyez-vous moduler les les cotisations
patronales en fonction de de de l'effort
qui est fait en matière d'emploi de
croissance par l'entreprise voilà des
propositions constructives j'ajoute à
cela qu'il faut naturellement relancer
la croissance il faut la relancer par
l'emploi il faut la relancer par les
salaires d'ailleurs une des propositions
fortes que j'ai fait dans la campagne
présidentielle me semble complètement
d'actualité il faut relancer la les les
salaires je pense qu'une augmentation de
de 1000 francs minimum des salaires de
tous les salaires de moins de 15000
franc relancerait les choses dans ce
pays voyez-vous mais là Monsieur oui
monsieur euh est-ce que vous pensez que
l'on doit continuer à faire la grève et
négocier pendant la grff comme le disait
hier soir ici même monsieur Blondel ou
est-ce que vous pensez que d'une
certaine façon on peut faire confiance
au gouvernement désormais arrêter la
grève et discuter mais il faut que le
mouvement se poursuive puisque
actuellement Monsieur jupet reste sourd
monsieur jupet dit les les Français ne
ne comprennent pas mes propositions
c'est lui qui ne comprend pas les
Français voilà la réalité il faut
aujourd'hui c'est simple il ne s'agit
pas d'attendre plusieurs jours il doit
négocier il faut qu'il retire son plan
et qu'il négocie je crois que c'est
extrêmement simple c'est ce que disent
les Françaises et les Français vous
savez les Françaises et les Français on
ont assez que depuis 15 ans on leur
rabâche toujours la même chose qu'on les
traite de haut qu'on les traite avec
arrogance qu'il y a au niveau de l'État
une des des des des docteurs je sais
tout qui décident de tout qui font tout
et qui ne tiennent pas compte de de ce
que disent les Français et ça c'est
insupportable ces mêmes gens des mêmes
écoles ils sont dans les mêmes conseils
d'administration tout ça ça ne va pas
c'est ce que disent aujourd'hui les
Français il faut écouter la France
Monsieur Je vous remcie